what has become of the Nobel Peace Prize
it was awarded to Obama of whom I'm
personally very fond before he'd
actually done anything it was awarded to
an sanzu Qi who's been criticized for
her proximity to military generals
reportedly responsible for human rights
violations against her Hingham muslims
and next up we're now hearing
potentially the queen for her six
decades of dedication towards keeping
the Commonwealth alive don't get me
wrong my problem is not with the claim
that the Queen is dedicated to the
Commonwealth she's been a tireless
advocate in securing its future my
problem is with the Commonwealth or as I
prefer to call it the Empire 2.0 the
Commonwealth was born out of a desire
and a need in Britain's case to keep its
Imperial relationships and influence
alive it has done so very successfully
that is not in my opinion something to
celebrate so when I first saw this topic
I honestly didn't know what to say I was
asked to respond to you I have really
I'm yes it is rather unusual because I
there's a few things that confuse me
right now aside from my view on the for
me my indifference to the Commonwealth
after Empire my indifference to the
Nobel Peace Prize after Obama as you
rightly said and my indifference to the
Queen after the invention of democracy I
think in different sums up my entire
stance to this but what I find really
strange is that you happen to get
exercised by the strangest of topics
like what I don't understand is on a
previous pledge change we had a
conversation about for example Churchill
and he refused to celebrate him and and
we had a now we're having a conversation
about the Commonwealth annual you know
understandably somewhat skeptical about
its purposes and yet outside of this
show you did write a column wanting to
celebrate Winnie Madikizela Mandela and
I'm just wondering what is it like what
it seems to me to be the case that
anything associated with a British
establishment you reject but anything
associated with people like Winnie who
you know had some really nasty stuff
attributed to her including burning
people alive with neck necklaces which
she called the fire burning petrol
necklaces what's higher
she put round people she arbitrarily
accused of being treacherous and burnt
them to death and so you know for me I
don't like that and I don't like the
Nobel Peace Prize famous to you what I'm
interested in is correcting imbalance I
do not hate Britain I actually love this
country this is my home I wouldn't talk
about these things if I didn't care
I wasn't invested in the mistakes I
think we're making here so that's why I
talk about written not because I hate it
or because I love attacking British
heroes or I love attack I actually want
them to improve it wasn't me saying that
she was flawless yeah well I don't I
don't like the celebration of
individuals as floors that's part of my
problem of British hero yeah I was
saying that the press were reporting her
as a mugger the mugger of a nation most
so many people in South Africa across
the world see her as the mother of the
nation a person without whose dedication
this this is hot this isn't that and
this is a bit of a distraction so let me
just give you my problem with the
Commonwealth right the reality is at the
moment right companies listed on the
London Stock Exchange control one
trillion dollars of resources in Africa
British companies owned a million square
kilometers of land in Africa four times
the landmass of Britain this is the
legacy of Empire Africa is getting
poorer while British companies and
British institutions continue to be
enriched a huge distraction from the
fact that Imperial relationships are
alive and well so while we're
celebrating it as this fluffy thing
based on shared values it is quite
clearly something legitimizing the
continuation of material legacy that is
very destructive two points who you say
you're not insulting the Queen you are
when you insult a common foe yes you are
because she has worked tirelessly over
the past 60 years to preserve but you
see my words this terrible before she
became there's a practically my work but
anyway but let's let the rhetoric okay
well can we just can somebody else talk
into your debate you mentioned the
convent it is a colossus it is an
economic power
these days it has a GDP of 10.45
trillion it has a diversity of markets
at the rest of the world can only dream
about its it has it has an economic and
cultural diversity which carries with it
a huge strength which is something I
thought you would celebrate but more
importantly you know you talk about what
it does it led the charge against
apartheid it's to the point where when
Mandela got elected as president of a
free South Africa the first thing he did
was rejoin the comp the Commonwealth
it stopped civil war in Rhodesia which
then became Zimbabwe what were you
flicking your eyes my missile and with
it the version of history that's
probably but you always you always just
appear in every version of British yeah
you can't celebrate having helped end
something without acknowledging the role
you played in it right through the 70s
and 80s Britain was up never mind what
it was is not what it is now I've just
described what it is now you quote me on
that you can't change history I've given
you to use modern parlance shall we see
what it says on the tin yeah so this is
what the Commonwealth and afterwards
I've got to know you and like you down
the the weeks and months we work
together apart from your insistence of
levelling Nelson's column but let's just
because as I read through this list I
want you to tell me anything you could
be against after the Commonwealth
Secretariat supports member countries to
achieve development democracy and peace
we are a voice for small and vulnerable
States and a champion for young people
we help to strengthen governance build
inclusive institutions and promote
justice and human rights the source is
the Commonwealth at four you can't argue
I've just given you the alternative
reality which is where resources are
flowing within the Commonwealth in the
Commonwealth Games happening claims
seven Camarena's after seven Cameroonian
athletes just went missing why do you
think that was do you think it's because
of the wonderful shared values in the
Commonwealth no it's because of poverty
in Cameroon the reality is the African
and some of the Asian members of the
Commonwealth are still characterized by
they have energy in Greece in Italy
in Portugal you're talking about
countries that are something about a
relationship between Britain when it's
for me I'm a bit like you imagined um I
really don't care if the Queen gets the
so the basic premise of the whole
discussion a thing that doesn't matter
than the kids do I care about the
Commonwealth yeah I think that's quite a
good institution I think anything that
brings a lot of countries together to
discuss some talk it comes your wife out
of Impa I think anything that brings
Carol Malone and Greg Dyer don't might
have to change my position but but I
don't I don't see the Commonwealth as it
is today forget about from when she came
for what it is today and as as an
organisation that is damaging to society
can we just remember this it is a
voluntary Association and therefore that
has organised at those countries that
have joined it join voluntarily and do
get some benefits from joining a plum
tree
in a context in which that these
countries were brought into the
globalized economy right by Britain as
the imperial power well they can't go it
alone yes they do choose to be talked
upon wealth but what is the history
behind that and I'm talking on screen in
the Nobel Peace Prize I can do nothing
about what my issue with that is that
it's in Britain's interests be in the
Commonwealth like we don't get prizes
for enjoying being part of an
institution that benefits us to continue
our Imperial or let me have they
voluntarily join they voluntarily
appointed the Queen as their symbolic
hand and two countries join without
having been in the Empire or Wanda and
Mozambique because they saw the benefits
of joining yes there are difficulties
with it but if those countries are
joining voluntarily because they see
certain economic and human rights and
political benefits then surely what the
solution should be is that we
acknowledge the history I agree but work
to strengthen that cooperation because
actually a bit like brexit and
between gum trees there is the better
long to reign over us but I'm afraid no
more time for the debate